Oh God oh this isn't gonna work at all
I'm gonna open why yes yes welcome basic
animal I like to arrive in style
we've already proven to ourselves and to
others that we are top 1% pilots haven't
we well yeah that was ages yeah we
cherry skills we joined Top Gun we did
or did we I don't remember we anyway we
need to become top 1% car pilots yes and
the best way to do that is to listen to
Baker Street is there and drive down the
highway so that's what we're gonna do so
I think the first challenge will be
quite simple ok we need to drive the
entire edge of Los Santos ok rules r sub
if you crash a car you have to change
your car but if you kill a person ok
have to shoot out one of your tires ok
you you yourself have to do that yeah I
need drive on the wrong side although i
don't believe they're called car pilots
I believe you are a captain of a car car
commander commander alright so we start
here up here past those shops obviously
take off a route down here and this
roads yeah back on here yeah all the way
around yep got a loop around here that's
gonna be okay on the beach on the beach
we're gonna have to cut in here and then
just back on here I think yeah so we're
doing our warm-up lap alright so we need
to oh god he's small wait yeah it means
you really get those heat of those tires
mind a pretty Oh crud I've just heated
up my front bumper scares as important
some warm also important it's not a 3 2
1 i'm gonna say red red red green ok ok
cozy right that's how they do rear edge
already green are you ready fashional
race ok ok red red red green go I saw
God excited already wrong side of the
road Christ yeah just like Burnett yeah
oh gosh Jesus oh [ __ ] are you guys
already God say uh oh my god what
happened I missed it well I had all he
was crud yeah just love her that car
laughs is this idea he corny Jesus he
stopped for me oh oh that looks fast
today oh it's too late I've already
taken it oh no watch it I think that's a
change of car there I think it is all
right there gay okay I must not kill the
owner
no sir are you in front of me yet um is
that you there chase car chase car okay
i am in some kind of like rolls-royce
phantom now okay oh this is difficult
when oh you've just left your car like
an obstacle in the middle of the road oh
god this is challenging pose please get
up please get up what's up oh yeah oh
yeah there goes a tire shoot i still
have your car all right there guys want
eyes down damn it nice cartwheel lady
this road is beautifully traffic-free oh
it's really heavy traffic for me oh its
own oh god damn it there's literally no
troll on my screen I don't want you here
we go mm how but my blood is on the car
that makes it my car run away run away
from the police so close so close to
what we far okay I like this section
this is fun there's no other vehicles
it's just you and the road aza fridge no
no oh god I parked my car quite
exquisitely hear that you've been and
crud this car that's a crash Go Go Go Go
Go it run Dungey bullets dodge bullets
touch my arm debts dodge bullets I'm dad
I tried to go to Billy no he's dodging
the bullets he's dodging the bullets oh
he shade it she said I'm on the beach
how is this there's no cars near here
he's made it ah you son of a round goes
wild I need to be on the other roads
above me I'm going to have your car
please Oh truck oh my god no the soldier
is like fellow soldiers the shark was
full of soldiers Sam they all hate me oh
god no if I die here oh oh dear I hope
you don't get Lords back no please
please don't pick me there oued [ __ ]
all right i'll put me in the swamp of
despair get me my car Oh close very
close though good effort
sev kindly stop your vehicle as you see
I just suffered a horrible for all right
i'm at the offer ready bit save you
gotta go in camera view man give the
problem is give this one a run around
this one actually has scuppered us
slightly how's it really yeah oh it
hasn't you made the jump oh god oh this
isn't gonna work at all I'm gonna oh yes
welcome amazing animal I like to arrive
in style impromptu race we're already
doing an impromptu race whoa that was
then they swerved ah barber neck and
neck I'm taking your car no you're not
ah Victor oh [ __ ] this is difficult to
handle on the beach you and I'm off I
know you're in a quad bike because I
have a quad bike I think I'm gonna take
the most direct route possible [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] haha said quad bike is not about
the quad bike is notice that count as a
crash yes well I mean it doesn't matter
but if we hit remember we both have to
change cars I remember Isis oh here we
go chase cox oh Christ no no no no this
one's mine oh god oh no I'm taking this
one time I'm taking the police car then
oh oh yeah dad this is where all that
time in Forza will whoop oh Jesus a big
truck ah ya know your front no truck and
the truck oh it's so close huh oh no
change cars chase cars get out of the
car lady oh [ __ ] [ __ ] me wow that's
what I just did final stages ok out yet
run I'll be so angry if you do that is
that you are you in that truck oh no I
kill the man what I know he's alive he
was just lying down ok i'm still barely
alive no its you
go up stopped and Eve I get you John oh
no that's what we started no you won
it's a you got my car yes Smosh start
shooting the cops tab I'll join you up
there what well i won I mean that was
all well and good so you won the race
yeah but you had all five of your senses
a new ones I use the most yeah so I'm
thinking let's do another thing i want
to show you how good I am at driving
yeah I'm gonna remove my site and you
need to be my eyes I'll be your eyes
smile okay can you be my hands I can be
whatever you want me to be and I be your
nose no okay that's good oh I didn't we
that's good more right right right more
the right all right okay that's very
nice very nice bitter right bitter laugh
haha you get elevations Olaf all right
all right left the glad you just seeing
you simple words I don't have it on me
and weaning that okay all right oh god
that's fine it's fine okay he was in
your way bit oh right right okay hey
that note that was left oh [ __ ] that was
so glum why are we on the rocks on the
roads hit more hard right a tree that's
left yes okay very good you've arrived
well done if we're gonna be pro drivers
we we need to be able to dodge more than
traffic we need to be able to dodge fire
okay like live on fire gunfire and
rocket fire okay great alright so the
best drivers they can do this you show
me the roots I'm never gonna doing this
jump oh I didn't get anywhere near
second time's a charm sab oh no oh yes
yours little landing this is kids first
lap Sorry Sorry oh [ __ ] cops you didn't
much better than me man as a tank Oh God
oh there's your dad there is your that I
need to get some speed this guy's no
joke BTW the fuzz
yo bullets bullet every last bit of a
left turn here in inverted donut
inadvertent doing up okay cops love the
donut a very glad game of chicken and he
goes right oh you're so much smarter so
there's another smart call he goes for a
cheeky little chump oh no you didn't oh
he lands the jump second big jump oh
he's you fix no no oh we rolled it oh no
dear that was Miss Kavita it was gonna
be like everybody's jump already bonus
god oh god oh you have to go right back
at this one and then yes oh such girl
driving but he's just taken the noise
it's okay it's not a race em I'll go
careful oh nice sorry just say well
you're a sippy alright stunt jump stunt
jump whoa are you gonna try and whoa yes
Here I am Here I am getting your car get
in go go go good yellow it's more lap
moisture take all that we're turning you
know maybe it I think it might be lap 10
complete all right can we get out of
here now no just need a little
transition oh oh oh your dad FL I'm
still a lot no I'm still alive I'm just
like oh [ __ ] i'm gonna get out way
losing me officer it up yes here we are
one plane to planned dose plane I'll
take the one in the hangar our gang a
loop around and landed the other way ok
you turn first sort of crash into yeah
well god oh [ __ ] you mean like that I'm
here we go I'm feeling a we can exactly
like that [ __ ] I would have hated me in
that plane example let's get Lonnie Oh
God God good landing Oh Atlantic hit me
we're at the Daytona date Turner that's
the one track I think it's meant for
horsies we're gonna pretend it's for
planes so I'm gonna go around this one
way you're gonna go around the other way
yeah we meet in the middle we're gonna
take it in turns to jump our cars over
the other 3321 run it race race we're
racing okay so we're not allowed to fly
except for the jumping over the other
person correct uh correct a correct oh
god this is okay alright okay alright
I'll corner I'll corner hug corner i'll
call it oh god I'm really good at this
oh god I think you've probably you've
already got all right here we go are you
gonna have to you got a lead on me jump
jump jump okay can i charter yes yes
never get a turn I'm tired n forget to
turn you better jump me sir you better
jump like the best of them job job oh
god oh yes oh god such good driving
skills ok your turn over oh it's a love
of many one very brave oh it's still
scary let's work oh alright ya need I
just gonna make it difficult for you you
better jump me you better jump me cuz
I'm not jumping I'm not jumping just
made it come on come on get that
speedboat is it gonna make it difficult
for you kiss me back I need some runway
to land on gets feedback oh no I sorry
I've accidentally but quite quite
luckily crashed my plane oh no I'm
worried about speed set up a Tekkit get
that get that plane in the air a quality
driver one of genuine quality yeah
should be able to jump over objects now
easily especially to make give it a
challenge I want you to try and jump
over me 1 i'm in a helicopter so I
position myself thusly there's your jump
up oh there you are hey how wonderful
you did really well I wasn't realize
you're gonna be there playsuits icahn
jump me jump may oh [ __ ] um
what happened you hit a tower you can do
it my totem spirit is statham them I see
you whoa you too i right I got you I got
you I don't have you I don't have you
swinging last minute off we go catch me
look I entry are you ha so close that's
true never join top gear with this you
got to give me you got to give me a car
I can catch them oh nice sign rich ok
it's ok it's ok beans beans beans all
right don't beat it just be me cut the
beans left their better being me serve
it a bit of right Hannibal bean catch
left hand bean in for the beans opines
are up catch catch catch like yes yeah
oh no I detonate all right here we go
bring it right wing it left compass no
no guys you try and up we go yes
hahahahaha I'm on it I'm literally I see
I see ah well we're not very good
drivers no not the best don't know if we
would make good transporters or delivery
men even I don't know if we will Ryan
Gosling's could we be in top gear I want
to eat are we in the top 1% a wee the
top gear I don't think we are the Tokyo
where maybe one of those middle gears Oh
like third like third I know nobody
third it's the worst there's everything
all this cam death death ah i'm guessing
us oh wait I throw it backwards reverse
I don't know how to do that I'm a
terrible driver so long cruel world can
the gas isn't working all right fine for
words gasps followed by swimming swim
let's go for a watery grave
would die to watch this go okay I gotta
die doing what i love i really hope i
can nail this driving bit whoa oh so
long cruel world been a pleasure to
drive by busy sir are you smoking are
you doing that how are you doing that do
you want one yes please wake up ah hey
you